so
elon musk is a billionaire
and one of the things that
really maybe it's almost a pet peeve it
really bothers me when the press and the
general public
will say well all those rockets they're
sending up there
those are just like the toys the games
that billionaires play
that to me billionaire has become a
dirty word
to use like as if money
can buy or has anything to do with
genius
like i i am i'm trying to articulate
a specific um line of
uh question here because it's just it
just bothers me i guess the question is
like
why how do we get here and how do we get
out of that because elon musk
is doing some of the most incredible
things that a human being
has ever participated in in mostly not
he doesn't build the rockets himself
he's getting a bunch of other geniuses
together
that have that takes genius that takes
genius but why
where did we go and how do we get back
to where elon musk is an
inspiring figure as opposed to a
billionaire playing with some toys
so this is the role of philosophy it
goes back to the same place it goes back
to our understanding of the world and
our role in it
and if you understand that the only way
to become a billionaire for example
is to create value value for whom value
for people who are going to consume it
the only way to become a billionaire the
only way elon musk
became a billionaire is through paypal
now paypal is something we all use
paypal is an enormous value to all of us
it's why
it's worth several billions of dollars
which elon musk could then
you know
but you cannot become a billionaire in a
free society
by exploiting people you cannot because
you'll be
you'll be laughed nobody will deal with
you nobody will have any interactions
with you
the only way to become a billionaire is
to do billions
of win-win transactions so
the only way to become a billionaire
free society is to change the world
to make it a better place billionaires
are the great humanitarians of our time
not because they give charity
but because they make them billions and
it's
true that money and genius are not
necessarily correlated but you cannot
become a billionaire without being super
smart
you cannot become a billionaire by
figuring something out that nobody else
has figured out
in whatever realm it happens to be and
that thing that you figure out
has to be something that provides
immense value to other people
where do we go wrong we go wrong
our culture goes wrong because it views
billionaires as self-interest as selfish
and there's a sense in which and not a
sense it's absolutely true
the billionaire doesn't ask for my
opinion on
what product to launch elon musk doesn't
ask
others what they think you should spend
his money on
what the greatest social well-being will
be ella i mean there's a sense in which
the rockets are his toys
there's a sense in which he chose that
he would have
he would be inspired the most he would
have the most fun
by going to mars and building rockets
and he's probably dreamt of rockets from
when he was a kid and probably
always played with rockets and now he
has the funds the capital to be able to
deploy it
so he's being selfish
obviously he's being self-interested
this is what elon musk is about
i mean uh the same with with uh jeff
bezos there's no committee to decide
whether to invent you know to invest in
cloud computing or not
bezos decided that and at the end of the
day
they are the bosses they pursue the
values they believe are good they pursue
they create the wealth
it's their decisions it's their mind and
the fact is we live in a world
where for 2 000 plus years
self-interest even though we all do it
just more extent nonetheless we
deem it as morally opponent it's bad
it's wrong i mean your mother probably
taught you the same thing my mother
taught me
think of others first think of yourself
last
the good stuff is kept for the guests
you never get to use the good stuff
you know it's others that's what the
focus of morality is now
no mother even no jewish mother actually
believes that
right because they don't really want you
to be last
they want you to be first and they push
you to be first but
morally that he taught their entire
lives and they believe
that the right thing to say and to some
extent do
is to argue for sacrifice for other
people
so most people 99 of people are torn
they they know they should be
selfless sacrifice live for other people
they don't really want to so they act
selfishly in their day-to-day life and
they feel guilty
and they can't be happy they can't be
happy and jewish mothers and catholic
mothers are excellent at using that
guilt
to manipulate you but the guilt is
inevitable because you've got these two
conflicting things
the way you want to live and the way
you've been taught to live
and what objectivism does is it at the
end of the day provides you with the way
to unite
morality a proper morality with what you
want
and to think about what you really want
to to conceptualize what you really want
properly
so what you want is really good for you
and what you want will really lead to
your happiness
so you know we reject the idea of
sacrifice we reject the idea of living
for
other people but that's but you see if
if you believe
if you believe that the purpose of
morality is to sacrifice for other
people
and you look at uh jeff bezos when was
the last time he sacrificed anything
right
he's living pretty well he's got
billions that he could give it all away
and yet he doesn't how day you know in
in my
in my talks i often position
and i'm going to use vogue sorry guys
yeah drop the conspiracy theory they're
all
bs completed nonsense there's not a
shred of truth
you know i disagree with bill gates on
everything political
i think he politically is a complete
ignoramus
but the guy's a genius when it comes to
technology and
and when he's just thoughtful even in
this philanthropy
he just uses his mind and i respect that
even though politically he's terrible
anyway
think about this who who had a bigger
impact on the lives of poor people in
the world bill gates or mother teresa
bill gates that's not even close and
mother teresa lived this altruistic life
to the course she lived it consistently
and yet she was miserable pathetic
horrible she hated her life she she she
was miserable
and most of people she helped didn't do
very well because she just helped them
not
die right yeah and then bill gates
changed the world
and he helped a lot of by providing
technology we even
philanthropy gets to them the food gets
the much faster more efficient
yet who is them all saint sainthood is
not determined based on
what you do for other people saint is
based on how much
how much pain you suffer i like to ask
people to go to a museum
and look at all the paintings of saints
how many of them are smiling
and i happy they've usually got arrows
through them and holes in their body
and they're just suffering a horrible
death the whole point of the morality we
are taught
is that happiness is immorality
that happy people cannot be good people
and that good people suffer and
suffering is necessary for morality
morality is about sacrifice
self-sacrifice
and suffering and at the end of the day
almost all the problems in the world
boil down to
that false view
you